dr nadpal do you think your members will
accept
matt hancock's apology at face value
or will they say that he's
only stepping down because he had no
choice
i think what our members are saying is
that they are feeling
absolutely exhausted after 15 months of
this pandemic many
have worked flat out without breaks they
worked during the lockdowns when
at the stay at home periods busier than
ever
about four intense say their mental
health is worse than before the pandemic
significantly
uh you have about one in three saying
they are going to be retiring the next
year
about one in five saying they'll leave
the nhs or reduce their hours
and remember this is on the back of
about eight and a half thousand
unfilled uh doctor vacancies about 80
000
vacancies in the nhs that have been
unfilled now this comes at a time
when the new health secretary uh was
going to see a baptism of fire
he won't have the luxury of a phased
handover
he'll have to make every day count and
um we're facing as you've said
a record five plus million patients on
waiting lists
and that includes about 400 000 who've
been waiting more than
12 months and that's not to inc and that
doesn't include about
20 million patients who were not seen in
outpatient clinics last year
so we really do have not an issue of a
a backlog crisis of care because many of
those patients will become more ill
as time goes on many of them have health
conditions which if they're not treated
promptly will become more serious and
what he will need to do
is manage that crisis in a way that that
delivers prioritization but also be
honest with the public about the length
of time it's going to take
and as a health secretary as a former
chancellor
he's going to need to negotiate the
resources that the nhs needs
the government has not costed for the
several billions of pounds that are
going to be needed
to address this backlog so he'll have to
do that as well
we'll come to the issue of resources in
a moment but um
mr javid will be talking to the press
probably within the next
hour or so what's the most important
thing you want to hear from him this
morning
well what i want to hear from him is one
that he understands
the workforce because the health service
cannot survive without its workforce he
needs to understand the pressures we
feel
he needs to understand the fact that we
need to have a proper rest
and to recover before the onslaught of
the recovery of the backlog of care
that's going to need to be delivered and
he needs to value us
and he will have to also address uh the
issues around pay and
the uh derisory one percent uplift that
has you know uh distressed
a lot of the workforce in terms of not
feeling valued but the other thing he's
going to logistically need to deliver on
is the vaccination program because we
are still in the midst of a pandemic
we have spiraling uh numbers of cases
now uh over
over 18 000 yesterday uh new cases we
are actually seeing increases in
hospitalization not at the level of
before
but it is impacting on hospitals uh at
the moment
and and he's going to have to get up to
speed and make sure that the adult
population
tens of millions of which have not yet
been vaccinated get vaccinated in the
coming
weeks it's a huge challenge let's let's
take a couple of those points
um the backlog other than saying he
recognizes how hard everybody's
worked the problems of morale
outlining the numbers involved in what
does he have
to do what do you want him to say he's
going to do
to fix that so what he needs to do
is first of all retain the workforce uh
he needs to
show he needs us he's need to speak to
the british medical association the
royal economy
what signal what signal would convince
you that that's happening
okay well one would be to be honest with
the public of the scale of work so that
he doesn't just put arbitrary targets
that we just somehow can magic up
delivering care
and clear the backlog in the next few
months that just isn't going to happen
he needs to make sure that there are
issues such as rest facilities
40 percent of doctors say they don't
even have a place to rest
uh in hospital he needs to make sure
that we can take leave we can
uh recover and then that we have a
prioritization program
where those patients who need to be seen
first are seen first
and that he puts in place the logistics
to make that happen
he needs to also make sure that we are
valued both in terms of
uh the terms and conditions we work in
but also pay
and he needs to retain the workforce and
also i should mention
uh do much more with the retired
workforce who are willing to come and
help
the government did not avail of the
retired workforce last year
they need to do that now especially at
this critical time
that's interesting because i was going
to say you know we want rest
we want recognition of the pressure that
people have been under
which sounds to me like you need more
doctors
like tomorrow but you can't train them
in less than seven years
so would uh him saying what i'm going to
do
is i'm going to pay and provide
incentives
for doctors to come out of retirement be
the sort of thing that you're looking
for
well you see i mean obviously retired
doctors can't do you know they've
retired but
large numbers have actually retired in
the last two years and so they can
certainly bring their skills
uh for example in terms of the huge
backlog they can be
uh looking at the prioritization of
patients they can actually be providing
a lot of the support by phone
and video consultations for in in
primary care for example
but you're absolutely right ultimately
we have been running a health service
that are tens of thousands of doctors
short and tens of thousands of nurses
short
and that recruitment won't be able to be
delivered immediately
but obviously what he has to commit to
is a training program that delivers that
in the years to come the other thing
that i'd like to say
is that we also have large numbers of
doctors who come from overseas
to the uk and at the moment there are
considerable hurdles and obstacles
that are preventing them coming here and
they're going to other nations
uh we need to make sure that as a as a
country
we're we're offering those doctors who
want to come and work here
the ability to do so and to not be and
to value
their contribution to the nhs many come
here for training because they need
postgraduate exam
qualifications from centers of
excellence in the uk and at the moment
many are being deterred from coming due
to certain bureaucratic
obstacles that need to be addressed
doctor mike pogba is clear
more immigrant doctors more doctors who
may have retired to who can help perhaps
do
things um you talked about pay the bma
has been at war with every health
secretary
since the inception of the nhs ken clark
once said that you've got to find a
concession to give the bma at least
once a year and um nye bevan who founded
the
uh the nhs said uh he
he was only able to do it by stuffing
doctor's mouth
with gold um is all of this
more to do with doctors wanting more
rather than patients needing more
no i i would absolutely refute that and
in fact i don't think this is actually
an issue about doctors per se
if you look at the healthcare workforce
you know all of the healthcare workforce
feel uh absolutely exhausted they have
actually delivered
during the most testing period the nhs
has faced since its inception
they've gone into work exposed
themselves to a deadly virus
back in last march and april when we
didn't even have enough ppe
uh and i think about 800 or 900
healthcare workers have died
many have fallen seriously ill and
large numbers of course have come from
doctors and nurses from overseas and
from ethnic minorities
i actually don't think this is an issue
about any one sector of the nhs
the entire workforce actually does
deserve
recognition for its efforts uh and it
does deserve
uh proper terms conditions and pay to
reflect that
so i don't think this is about about
politics at all this is about fair
recognition